saviez-vous qu'en langue anglaise tic et
tac s'appelle chippendale et c'est aussi
une référence ship and tails mais en
français ils ont toujours été tictacs et
je sais déjà que cette aventure vous en
apprendra encore plus sûres et si je
disais quelque chose comme
et
je veux juste vous rappeler que je serai
à la fan comme cet après midi attention
je maintiens ma pomme et tu sais j'ai
aussi actualiser mon look tu propre acte
aurait plus de fans ici citic faisait
ces événements avec toi je n'avais pas
pensé à lui depuis un moment je devrais
l'appeler faut voir comment va sa vie la
fille c'est ce qu'il ya de pire c'est
pour ça que vous avez besoin d'une bonne
assurance
il sage sur mon téléphone fixe j'aime
pas du tout
est fouillé le périmètre aucun indice
pourquoi y en aurait si tous disparu en
un mois et pas un seul indice
gym est atteint
tu as l'air différent c'est pas secret
et tout le monde sait que je me suis
fait refaire en 3d qu'est ce que tu
deviens tu ce su cela d'autres choses
vague pour remplir l'espace de cette
conversation pull je crois qu'on
pourrait aller voir ce qu'on peut
trouver et ensuite transmettre ça à
l'ophite et steckler mais si tout ce
qu'on va faire donc tu dis que les
rangers du risque sans de retour oui
les foules et là vous n'avez rien à
faire je déteste votre attitude
correspond
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que tu regardes la tranche
mentez yeux bizarres sont vides
par ici il va les chercher
fabuleux
[Musique]
en plus j'ai toujours préféré alvin et
les chipmunks tuer un monstre
[Musique]
super professionnel en même temps chiche
tu me doit un colosse en mars spécifique
quoi c'était 2 du cab est le livre des
records c'est à quoi est là et on l'a
raté